es kommt heute zu einem neuen video vom
spiel finde mich heute nicht alleine
sondern zusammen mit einer person mit
der eltern die sich mit simon
ich habe mir bei einem
spielwarengeschäft in der nähe ein spiel
gekauft das heißt da sind wir beim
menschen drauf gemalt von falco wir sind
seine menschen und seine tennis krimi
ballmaschine keine ahnung was und diese
maschine geschleudert bälle weg und die
personen müssen die mit den körben auf
dem kopf irgendwie fand ich würde sagen
wir seien nochmals zusammen auf ich weiß
nicht ob der batterien drin sind oder
auch noch batterien das sind so
tischtennisbälle dann tatsächlich ein
paar austauschen und an spielen
[Applaus]
und sieht das ist tatsächlich eine
ziemliche also meine damen und herren
jetzt hier diese maschine endlich
zusammengebaut es war sehr schmerzhaft
das zusammenbauen aber wir haben es
hingekriegt und wir werden die maschine
jetzt leicht nach vorne irgendwo
hinstellen und dann wird zuerst wir
schicken wir anfangen uns 30
[Musik]
da sieht man jetzt das stück verloren
hat muss erst anfangen das heißt simon
sucht sich schon mal im tecdax die sg
hier ist ja voreingestellt ist nicht an
eine ich bin stolz oder die ganze zeit
noch links nach rechts es könnte sein
dass ich mal pausen laufen muss und auch
für 1000 euro bekommen haben die macht
zurück
[Applaus]
[Musik]
2 ok meine bilanz war 2 das schauen wir
mal ob du das schlank 3 2 1
[Musik]
nein
das ist neu
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
vagnis man runde zwei ist ja so machen
dass wir so wie überlegt da für diese
beiden tun aber die darf man nicht
fangen also freundin wir machen jetzt
die reihenfolge wir nehmen nur die
meisten kaum ein eingreifen dahinstehen
ich weiß nicht wie weit dieses ding
jetzt nicht fallen weil sie jetzt euch
und noch immer der fall
nach einer weile
die arbeit informierte gelben und das
war's dann kommt der punkt erreicht
werden bei diesen tieren und guten muss
die meisten fangen aber darf nicht die
gelben fangen können wieder helfer
weil er nicht weiterkommen
[Musik]
jetzt kommen noch die bayern da wir
beide keinen punkt gemacht
doch gott entscheidet sich wohl die
letzte runde auf diese ganzen gewisse
durch noch auswerten kann
wir haben uns jetzt für die dritte
finale entscheidende runde überlegt das
film und falco die schiedsrichter mehr
oder weniger sind und simon nicht werden
beide hier in dem spielfeld stehen und
versuchen uns gegenseitig weg zu starten
wir jetzt alles voll gestopft mit gelbem
mit weißen welt wieder fangen was wir
wollen und ich würde sagen
los gehts entscheidende runde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
pings kaputt meine damen und herren
wollten eine letzte runde machen
triebwerk ist leider auf jeden fall des
umbaus kappt deswegen will ich sagen
würde das ist die erste runde gewonnen
kriegt keine offizielle gewinner
ich schenke dir an der stelle nach den
jetzt begraben gehen anders stelle sich
jetzt allerdings auch das video beenden
meine damen und herren das haben auf
jeden fall sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr wenig spaß gemacht manchmal
heutige sache herr zurück simon gewonnen
die zweite runde war unentschieden von
ergebnissen an der stelle den hier wie
das ganze mit gummiball weitergeht und
ob sie ihn begraben werden oder was mit
dir machen werden zitieren simons blog
blog ist unten verlinkt und jetzt bei
der dame kommt nach haut wo glas was
jetzt hier vom video das war's jetzt
hier vom video hier können jetzt
jemanden kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job ausschenken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auch
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]